all right it's almost time to say
goodbye but we have one more holiday
story to share this is what I'm
[Music]
liking so everyone knows Santa's elves
live at the North Pole but did you know
that he's got a few working on the side
in Virginia I didn't think so it is true
though the Danville Police Department
calls themselves Santa's little blue
helpers each year they donate hundreds
of toys to kids in need and it's having
a real impact on the community it's
beautiful we have Corporal Brooks and
Sergeant Ferguson from the Danville
Police Department to talk about it they
watch On WSLS 10 Rowan Oak what's up
y'all I am so good thank you so much for
joining us thank you for your service
first and
foremost like how many kids are we
talking about y'all collect a lot for
the kids right yeah well we're trying to
service over 500 youth um children kids
um we want to make sure that they um
have something with trying to be a
positive relationship with the youth and
police by giving them something and they
get to know us and help the families
it's a great thing when you see parents
come in and they're like oh wow I I
wouldn't have been able to get this and
then also the community donates and
helps us out so to make sure we reach
our goal so how what is the impact
you've kind of seen on the community
because of all this well we've been
doing this for about five years and it
gets our officers out of the cars get to
talk to people we know people on a 101
basis now and it also has helped our
crime rate our crime rate is almost at a
almost a 40-year low um wow that's
amazing yeah oh my gosh well thank you
guys so oh go ahead go ahead man' I was
just gonna say when we got our job a lot
of things was going on with the youth so
that's why we're building these positive
relationships and doing this is it
turned around a lot absolutely it's a
great idea for every Community thank you
guys so much I'm not only liking your
post I'm loving your post right now and
that's not all our season one partner
pilot pin makers of friction the goto
rasal pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
Believe in the work that you're doing so
they're giving you $1,000 that's $500
each if you want to buy some more
toys thank you guys so much for your
service and your heart such a beautiful
thing and thank you to all our guests
this hour shann and dhy Ariana Maddox as
Smith Samantha and Lauren Ash yall have
a great day and it it's not try
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home